if you were to date what is it that
would be a great that I'm looking for
I've made this list so okay good I want
it it would need to be someone who also
have has kids so that they understand
that like they can never come first
that's a big one then it would have to
be someone that's okay with seeing me
once a week for a 2hour window also they
have a driving force in their life that
like isn't me you know what I mean I
can't be the center of somebody's life I
can't have someone's world revolve
around me I tend to get into those kinds
of relationships and it just never ends
well because ultimately whatever vision
of me they're projecting on to me isn't
who I actually am and then when they see
who I actually am they're like oh well
you know uh